can you explain what thermal time is
this is my question and then I head up
I had some notes so the conventional
Logic for interpreting this relation is
time
gives you a notion of energy which gives
you a notion of a macroscopic state now
you're saying that this can be reversed
okay now that's so using that as a
jumping off point and remember that the
audience understands what entropy and so
on is
okay perfect so um
um
there are a number of open questions uh
in understanding time
I think there are a lot of things we
have understood
that time doesn't work or the way we
usually think about we have understood
this with special activities General
activity with statistical mechanic but
then there are some open questions
and uh among the open questions it's
following
uh once we go
to a general relative relativity
description about the world
um
the so the scripture of the world large
enough to include the relativistic
properties of gravity
then the theory we use does not have a
lot of variables
variable things we measure but none of
this is naturally identified as a Time
variable
that's the point
and I'm not talking for those who are
more learned among those who you guys
who listen I'm not talking about in a
given space-time which one is time of
course in a given space time there's
there are clocks that measure proper
time along each line we know this stuff
but I'm talking about the evolution of
space-time itself I mean the Einstein
equation that evolved for Gravity space
time matter everything in that Evolution
this evolution is given as a relative
evolution of variables and not evolution
in time
then Case by case we can identify you
say well let's call this time
one one particular variable this works
um in fact this is the way the world is
at the level of of generativity
and also at the level of a general
relativistic Quantum field for Quantum
reality and then there is something
funny
and that's a question
in our experience it's very clear uh
which variable is time it's it's a one
that clocks are connected to okay the
the time value is completely different
than the other variables
profoundly different
and uh so how is it possible that from a
theory in which no specific variable is
temporal then
for us
uh one variable which is the position of
the clock is definitely completely
different than the others because it
distinguishes paths from the future in
such a way
so I worked on that and I wrote some
papers sign of papers on that and a key
paper with a French mathematician field
medal alone con the spectacular and
Brilliant and good mathematician because
we got to this idea both of us
independently in a very different paths
and we wrote this paper together
he came to that from pure mathematics I
came that from thinking about physics
and so the idea is a speculative idea
I'm not sure it's correct uh it's not
something people agree upon but I I put
in the book as a as a speculation it's
something I I think in some sense should
be right
um and that is a following
that when we distinguish the time
variable from the other it's because of
of what peculiar what is peculi of time
that the past is so different from the
Future Okay the right right and left are
not different up and down are not so
different a little bit different but we
understand that uh past and future are
completely different
and but the big difference the the many
differences which we can write down but
the big difference is that entropy grows
toward the future okay and this is a
reason we remember the pastor not the
future this is the reason the future
feels open this is a reason uh uh if you
if you if you sure feel the backward the
movie backwards it's obviously backward
and so on so forth so what characterize
the time direction is not mechanics is
entropy an entropy means statistical
mechanics and means uh uh that we're
giving a close grain description of the
world in terms of temperature entropy so
we have many degrees of freedom and we
are
um we are
uh uh not describing all of them but
only a few of them this is what entropy
is about so there's something about the
fourth time which has to do with the
fact that
um
we don't describe the microphysics we
have this macroscopic description
now it is so
then
it's very tempting
to reverse the story
between the flow of time
and the macrophysics okay in the
following sense
we learn in in physics textbook that the
time passes okay systems automatically
equally break because of the second law
of Thermodynamics so they go to or
equilibrium and when they go where they
go to equilibrium they go to a state
which is an equilibrium State and this
equilibrium state
is described in the physics as one
particular state in the sense of
statistical mechanics a probability
distribution or possible configurations
okay
so the logic think of the logic time
passes
and this determines a particular state
now the idea
Alan and I uh God independently is that
maybe this is the other way around
we're getting drunk
since in the fundamental theories
there's no preferred time but there are
States
right there are States because uh
because uh uh we don't see the details
of the world where the proximal
description was so we give a the
schedule of the World which is a a a
statistical State a distribution of a
possible configuration
now given a flow of time it it
determines one particular distribution
maybe we should view the other way
around given a probabilistic
distribution of the world what we know
about the world this determines the flow
of time you can mathematically compute
it that way from the distribution you
can do a simple and and other people
wrote down these mathematical passages
um
we
statistical state of the world produces
a type variable
and this is the idea of terminal time
an Ancon pushed this father
because
um
if you have a quantum mechanical system
by necessity you have some Randomness
because quantum mechanics is Randomness
because if you remember X and P you you
they don't commute it is no
commutativity implies some randomness
so one of the big big mathematical
results that Alan Cohn has uh obtained
is that
um
using this Randomness he could show that
any state
in the sense of quantum mechanical
States
determines a flow of time and I don't
want to enter into the complication of
const mathematics is for Neumann
algebra's complicated stuff in some
sense this evolution is unique in some
very peculiar senses evolution is unique
so what Connie says that automatically
once you have the randomness of quantum
mechanics that you have a time flow
the terrible time idea is is a simpler
version of that it's just if you don't
know the details
your lack of knowledge of the details is
such that mathematics is sufficient to
pick up a specific time flow
okay
so uh you see if you study generativity
the question is uh
uh which one of the variable do you want
to call time backup and the answer is
well they're all pretty the same but
if you don't know the details and you
have a foggy version there's one that is
preferred
and let me give you
if I have one more minute on this
question correct
a simple version of this story
um
in special relativity
you have many time variables because if
you move if you and I are moving respect
one another we have different Lawrence
type in the Lawrence information there's
TNT Prime at different times right they
all the same it's not one is better than
another they're all the same okay
suppose you have a cloud
which is hot when you go out in the
universe and the cloud is hot
if it is hot
okay if you have a number of particles
they move there's no preferred time but
if you have a hot Cloud this is hot it
has a temperature
which is determined by the fact that it
got in equilibrium with itself
but it got an equilibrium in one
Lawrence frame not in all Lawrence frame
it's it's equilibrium in the frame in
which the the cloud as a whole the
center of mass of the of the cloud is is
is is stationary
it's only in this Frame that the
distribution is the distribution is the
the boltzmann distribution that you
expect
from the
so if you know the distribution if you
have a macroscopic description of that
you pick up a time I preferred Lawrence
time
so you see microscopically
you don't see any preferred time but
macroscopica is one perfect time and the
idea is that that's exactly what
happened in the world I mean we we live
in a world we interact with the world
macroscopically obviously there is a
past in the future obviously there is a
a Time Direction but that's because we
use this macroscopic variables if we
were really interacting with old degrees
of freedom at the level of generativity
all variables will will be equally
temporal variables
okay so let me see if I can understand
this and you can correct what I'm saying
time applies energy implies macro State
as we talked about before and then you
can reverse that but then I see that as
a trade-off between Precision so if we
were more precise we wouldn't see time
that's where Alan at which I'm going to
mispronounce but the French
mathematician you mentioned the fields
medalist Alan konis that's Elaine conus
that's where he comes in by saying this
guy clearly you can never be extremely
precise anyway given quantum mechanics
so that's why Quantum mechanically you
can just you can induce time in that
regard is that correct okay correct
exactly exactly so let me stress that
it's a beautiful idea I love it I think
it's right but I'm not sure it's a very
speculative idea so um I I I people have
been complaining about that and it's I
think it's an open question what are
their complaints to help us
um the complaint is that the main
complaint is that it's not developed
well enough because
[Music]
um
it in an equilibrium situation
you need an equilibrium situation to
single out the time value
uh but actually what we really what
really uh what we really do in our life
when we pick up a time variable is
precisely because it's not an
equilibrium situation capacity for the
future
so in a sense it would be good to extend
this uh thermal time outside the simple
equilibrium case in which past the
future the equilibrium we don't
distinguish anymore
um uh past and future to to make this
story really completely coherent
you just watched a clip from the
theories of everything channel for the
full video and all its magnificence then
click here and if you'd like to see more
then subscribe enjoy